[Música]
hace un tiempito fui a un encuentro de
innovación en educación
alcácer kita
cuando llegué me dieron una tarjeta para
poner mi nombre que me hicieron que el
orgánicas y la ponía en una maceta y
ofrecer una planta de tomate
después nos dieron los cascos de
realidad virtual y en una nube voladora
un gurú de la innovación nos decía que
para mejorar la escuela proponían
educación centrada en el interés de los
chicos y la mayéutica como método de
enseñanza de aprendizaje
yo pensé la educación centrada en el
interés de los chicos tiene como
propuesta más de 100 años entre nosotros
y la mayéutica era el método que usaba
sócrates para enseñar a sus discípulos
con preguntas y con respuestas
esta es la innovación que nos están
proponiendo
yo siento que es como con el mito de
largos y largos es el primer bajo que
existió por ser el barco más viejo de
todos las piezas iban desgastando y
había que cambiar un mástil quebrado por
uno nuevo una vela jada por otra
si van cambiando las piezas con los
arreglos y la pregunta que cabría
hacerse es si sigue siendo el mismo
barco yo creo que sí y con la educación
siento que pasa algo parecido cambiamos
una pieza más vieja por una más nueva
pero la escuela nuestra vieja y querida
escuela sigue siendo la misma
en el colegio donde yo trabajo como
profe de matemáticas pusieron
televisores y conexión en todas las
aulas y es eso ponemos pantallas
aplicaciones luces de colores el último
grito de la tecnología pero lo que no
estamos teniendo en cuenta es que la
escuela es una tecnología
hace 200.000 años que el ser humano
habita la tierra desde que estamos acá
transmitimos de una generación a otra
los saberes que consideramos
imprescindibles para poder sobrevivir y
para integrarnos en la cultura durante
muchísimo tiempo esa transmisión fue
oral y el primer gran cambio que hubo
fue con la escritura la escritura cambió
la forma de almacenar esos saberes la
forma de procesarlos y la forma de
transmitir las se masificó cuando
inventamos la imprenta de tipos móviles
pero el primer gran cambio fue en 1630
cuando un teólogo de lo que ahora
conocemos como la república checa-
propuso un dispositivo de transmisión de
saberes muy particular
eran edificios a lo largo de lo ancho
del territorio con habitaciones en donde
se separarían a los chicos de la zona
por edades y en donde adultos
especialistas enseñarían los mismos
contenidos a los mismos chicos de la
misma edad al mismo tiempo
a esto a este dispositivo tecnológico lo
llamo escuela y el principio en el que
se basaba era que todo es saber
producido por el ser humano
tiene que ser para todos los seres
humanos este concepto se llama pan sofía
todo el saber humano es para todos los
seres humanos en 1630 convenio el que
propuso esto cuando decía todos eran
realmente a todos hablaba de varones y
de mujeres
de estudiantes más aventajados y menos
aventajados
hace 350 años que existe la escuela y
así como tuvo un comienzo la historia va
a tener un final no es que yo quiera que
se termine mi negocio me quedaría sin
trabajo pero
los cambios en el procesamiento de la
palabra ahora en la era digital los
cambios en las formas de producir los
cambios en las relaciones sociales entre
las relaciones de poder entre
generaciones más jóvenes y generaciones
más viejas nos dan la pauta de que ese
cambio está sucediendo
y después de la escuela que va a venir
para poder contestar esa pregunta
formamos un grupo de investigación con
especialistas de la educación de
diversas áreas lo llamamos proyecto para
sofía
imaginar el futuro de la educación sin
caer en dispositivos que se parezcan a
la escuela no es una tarea muy fácil
investigamos en tecnología y en la forma
que tiene de afectar a nuestro cuerpo y
afectar a cómo aprendemos investigamos
en filosofía y nuestra primera gran
sorpresa fue cuando hacíamos el
ejercicio de tratar de pensar cómo sería
la educación dentro de 20 o 30 años y
nos enteramos de que eso que estábamos
imaginando
estaba sucediendo del otro lado del
mundo
en el 2016 en nueva zelanda se propuso
un proyecto de ley en donde por primera
vez un estado ofrecería a las familias
la posibilidad de cursar desde nivel
inicial hasta nivel universitario sin
pisar jamás un aula
se llaman comunidades de aprendizaje
online cool es la sigla en inglés
y la novedad no sería la educación a
distancia eso ya existe hace bastante
tiempo la novedad es que por primera vez
un estado estaba proponiendo esto de
manera masiva
nos surgieron un montón de dudas
respecto de cómo funcionaría esta
alternativa qué pasa con los procesos de
socialización de los estudiantes por
ejemplo qué pasaría con aquellos
contenidos que no son de una disciplina
como por ejemplo esperar mientras otros
está hablando o reconocer al otro como
alguien distinto a uno
la educación con plataformas educativas
se está avanzando en todo el mundo de la
mano de empresas de la educación en
nuestra región también está avanzando
nos hacemos muchas preguntas al respecto
de esto
la soberanía pedagógica que es la
capacidad de cada pueblo de decidir por
sí mismo cuáles son los saberes
importantes para integrarse a la cultura
se encuentra en una encrucijada
se imaginan si se pudiera tener registro
de todos los problemas de matemáticas
que resolvieron en su vida
el tremendo
esta sería una información mucho más
profunda de lo que surge de un estanque
o en el muro de facebook mucho más
íntima que un perfil ideológico sobre lo
que decimos en las redes sociales un
registro de todos los problemas de
matemática que resolvieron en su vida se
llama huella cognitiva
permitiría hacer un mapeo de cuáles son
los caminos que suele tomar la mente
para resolver un problema cuáles son los
caminos que se suelen descartar cuáles
son las áreas de más creatividad y las
áreas de menos creatividad de cada uno
de nosotros en este momento otros países
de la región tienen toda su educación
matemática a través de plataformas
educativas la información de todos esos
problemas que resolvieron los chicos se
guardan en los servidores de la empresa
que provee la plataforma en su país de
origen
qué hacemos con toda esta información
para que servirá y quien lo controla
como les decía antes investigamos en
cuáles son los efectos que tiene el
avance de la tecnología en sus
intervenciones en nuestros cuerpos
la tecnología nos lleva a ser algo más
que seres humanos nos lleva a hacer algo
menos hace unas semanas el director de
ingeniería de google contaba que
una de sus investigaciones proyectaban
para dentro de solamente 12 años
estar en condiciones de implantar en el
neocórtex cerebral nanobots que nos van
a permitir conectarnos con la nube sin
necesidad de un dispositivo en el medio
ser una idea lo que cambiaría el
concepto de aprender con un dispositivo
como éste o el concepto de tomar una
evaluación o el concepto mismo de
escuela
queremos que sea una corporación la que
maneje la que esté intermediando entre
nosotros y el acceso a esos saberes
podremos garantizar que todo el saber
humano es para todos los seres humanos o
será como con las otras aplicaciones que
hay una versión básica y gratuita para
todos pero si quiero tener la versión
completa tengo que pagar el upgrade
parece un capitulo de black mirror pero
es concreto es real y es para dentro de
12 años nada más
la escuela es un artefacto social
histórico así como tuvo un comienzo va a
tener un final
y creemos que todo el saber humano es
para todos los seres humanos la paz
sofía no se negocia
el futuro de la educación más allá de la
escuela nos ofrece escenarios
fantásticos pero también preguntas que
no podemos permitirnos esquivar o
pensamos en estas cuestiones o vamos a
ser pensados por otros
[Aplausos]